the left has no principles and so there
is the left this just whatever sign
helps them get power hey I'm Dave Rubin
and this is the Rubin report if you're
new here click the subscribe button and
make sure that the Bell is solid to get
all notifications and more importantly
joining me today is the founder and
president of Turning Point USA the
largest conservative college student
organization in the United States of
America as well as the host of the
charlie kirk podcast charlie kirk
welcome back at the reuben roohorse dave
glad to be here that was the longest
intro i've ever given well thank you all
and during that all in one breath were
also basically dressed exactly the same
here yes we have some agreements but we
also have some disagreements so there's
gonna be an odd mirror I think we've
actually started to agree on almost the
big every big thing over the last couple
years well a lot of the things actually
so you were on the show what it's about
two years or it's like January of 18 can
you area eighteen so that's like over a
year and a half ago basically and I've
gotten to know you quite well in the
last year and a half we we've toured
together usually with Candice Owens
obviously and I want to cover all new
stuff here but I do want to quickly just
talk about turning-point briefly because
when we do these events together and I'm
sure we've got some coming up in the
fall you always make a point of saying
to the audience a if you've got
questions and you disagree with us come
up first so we always take questions for
people that disagree with us first and
we treat them as respectfully as humanly
possible or at least as respectfully as
they treat us but also me and you have
some disagreements and we go up there
and we talk them out so how is it that
so many people on Twitter think you're a
fascist
what would a strange concept how is that
for a segue you see they're very good it
was right into it yeah what a strange
concept to hear the other side to give
people a platform that you totally might
fundamentally disagree with then have a
conversation about it see where you
might be able to build consensus find
the disagreements then find why you
disagree which is super important so you
did do you disagree because you have
different data inputs or do you disagree
cuz you're different philosophical
inputs to totally different things
yeah so for example someone might say
well I want universal health care
because it worked so well all across the
world
well okay let's talk about that and you
can maybe deconstruct some of the
failures of socialized medicine or I
want universal healthcare because I
believe healthcare is our right
that's different the right those are
very different otally different but and
then you're all the sudden have a
conversation and then what happens after
that conversation you've seen it Dave I
mean you spoke with us at University of
Connecticut you spoke with us at UC
Berkeley you subbed in for us up in the
Northeast New Hampshire right yes yes
you and Candice didn't show for that was
that right the one that I dealt with
those lunatics yourself thank you again
yeah of course and you got viral you did
go brilliantly I think and and Dave
you'll I think reinforced this every
time we get a chance to go to these
campuses and have these conversations
there seems as if at least with the
individual student and the people in the
room there's a level of respect for at
least our our worldview and our position
mm-hmm from even those that disagree
with us and we like to say that it's not
that these students are opposed to our
ideas and they're not exposing them at
all in the first place and just being
able to have this sort of marketplace of
ideas and you and I will disagree on
some things yeah sometimes which is
amazing I mean who wants to go listen to
a bunch of people say I agree me too I
agree you don't want that yeah by the
way what we called college right where
that is called College Sally and we're
gonna get into that because you and I
are having a major issue right now with
the with the big tech centric censorship
stuff which is it's a personal issue for
both of us as podcasters and youtubers
and the rest of it but it's also a
really serious philosophic issue but you
know one of the things that I always
find most interesting at the events that
we do is a lot of times they'll be like
a crew in the back of the room that
clearly is not there because they like
us but you know sometimes they'll sit
there respectfully but they'll kind of a
scowl on their face so they'll be
giggling or whispering to somebody gonna
make of it but but then by the end when
you're expecting that when you say to
them if you disagree with us come up
first a lot of them just kind of leave
because I think something does actually
happen over the course of the hour hour
and a half when they go oh these people
that I'm heard of heard or told her all
right or fascist or something they're
not all that bad and then suddenly they
feel sort of foolish well and what I
love is that we're sitting on stage we
have you we have a great Candice Owens
and they're here calling us racist
they're calling us bigoted they're
calling us backward thinking a homophobe
homophobic a homophobic right of course
[ __ ] right all these sorts of things
yeah
and all of a sudden listen to this
message of Western classical liberal
ideas of listening to other side and
opening up markets and the individual
matters the most we live in a great
country and Dave I have to say I am a
robber baron of one of the things that
you say I've stolen it probably thirty
times so as long as you credit me now
above more than fifty percent um I will
put out credit right now I credit you
sometimes a lot credit you right now
where you asked the audience you say who
here has it worse than your grandparents
and no Han I've never seen a handle up
yeah and isn't that a great just just
kind of visual representation of how
beautiful this country you know there's
one time just in the last few months so
I've asked that question hundreds of
times at this point and literally nobody
then about a month ago I was at Santa
Clara and I asked the question that
somebody for fellow subways it's even
better the guy raises his hand he says
that he's a Chinese immigrant to the US
and he moved here you know five or ten
years ago and that he has it worse than
his grandparents because the Communists
took all of his grandparents stuff and I
thought wow that's as good as it gets
that's it that is as good as you get but
that that sort of argument is not made
ever on college campuses through the
traditional institutional professor and
academic elites instead the
philosophical position that is
predominantly put towards students is
that America is a mistake the ideas that
you grew up with are flawed but we have
all the answers we and our couple
thousand professors in the Academy were
the smart ones we're the philosopher
kings that Plato used to talk about give
us the power and give us the trust to
how to run society and things will get
better and they focus on the inequality
they focus on the structural deficits
and of course there will always be
structural deficits I mean if a society
and ends up eradicating them I don't
think that's gonna happen in our
lifetime there'll always be outliers
there's gonna be people but generally
think you can have to kill a lot of
people to do that to look at Soviet some
yeah like we only have to kill 60
million people to try to you know get to
agreement well that's that's hard to
swallow on
and it didn't even work after that you
know and look at Communist China under
under Mao anyway so the the Academy is
is rooted in not teaching the other
right other ideas but teaching their
ideas the monolithic ideas and that's
why what we're doing and we love
bringing you to campus what we're doing
at Turning Point USA's have you so much
resonance and we have grown so
substantially since the last time you
and I sat down are you see our
conferences that was there all the
students there growing you know
exponentially and
was it your idea to just kind of so make
them more fun because I speak at all
sorts of stuff and there's definitely a
difference between going to a
turning-point event in the way the crowd
it feels a little bit almost like you're
at a pro wrestling match and I I mean
that in the most I mean that in the fun
way because even whatever they're
chanting and sometimes they're chanting
mag or whatever it is it's like they're
not doing it out of races or they're
doing it out of like let's have some fun
just with some of this and I don't even
think all of them are our pure mega
people or anything it's just like oh
let's not make politics just endlessly
painful and boring life to hear one more
lecture from someone like looks like the
shutting them in in Beach like okay I
got it
you know and that's fine you can listen
to those scholars but the traditional
conservative conference is just here's a
bunch of white papers here's how correct
we are let's look at these charts and
then you say okay I agree but what's
happening is that we're also in a
culture war and you go to these turning
point you know say events it's the music
it's the bright lights it's the t-shirt
cannons and all of a sudden you're
having fun yeah and who's that the left
is anti fun I mean they're anti comedic
and expression they're anti creativity I
mean everything is you're gonna defend
somebody I mean I'm surprised I really
am surprised we have these t-shirt
cannons that they have not said that we
are making fun of you know some sort of
victims of some sort of shooting because
we have t-shirt cannons well you guys
get it you just handed it well there we
go so that they'll they'll come after
that look to it with us later but you
know I'm joking of course but the point
is that we try to make it high-energy
and we do and because that our
conferences and our events you know grow
substantially so what did the
Conservatives do wrong if these
classical liberal to conservative ideas
are the right ones and I think I'm
pretty much with you on that at this
point well where did the Conservatives
screw up that they lost the Academy
there
the media they lost academia they lost
everything that led us to an entirely
brainwashed generation of Millennials
and then and then a group of se lefties
that are older than them that just
acquiesced to it out of sheer fear so we
did two things made a little wrong one
on policy philosophy which I think
you'll find interesting and the one just
kind of structurally unlike an
infrastructure side of what we've done
wrong
first of which I think that we lost a
lot of young people and a lot of people
that consider themselves liberals to
this day just over multi decades and
multi generations of identifying
themselves as that based on doing what
we now accuse the left of doing which is
for many years Republicans in the 70s
and 80s and I'm an avid Jellico
Christian Bible believing that angelical
Christian and so I have I think some
standing to say this the the right in
America was telling people how to live
their life mm-hmm
not everyone but boy did it sure sound
like that was that this is the correct
way this is the only way and then you're
mixing it's really close to mixing
deeply held religious beliefs and
government policy do you think they
meant it in that that's truly what they
wanted say the evangelicals or the
religious right or that it was purely a
political ploy because a lot of people
look back to george w bush's reelection
it's hard gay marriage like this wedge
issue which I don't think george w bush
specifically cared about gay marriage
but in that way it was a political tool
not necessarily an ideological it's
tough to say I mean I will I will speak
to the fact that I think conservatives
today on the right and you'll agree this
we have the moral high ground because
the ethos of the modern new conservative
movement is don't tell me how to live my
life I don't tell you how to live your
life don't take my stuff I'm not gonna
take your stuff that's really the ethos
of why we have the moral high ground as
that libertarian side I keep telling you
guys about just keep sticking with that
good I agree and there's some things
that I think yeah we'll get there with
more populist time but that's okay with
that being said so where did we go wrong
is we become we became the angry
librarian in the room in the 70s and 80s
don't have fun stop doing this and again
as an evangelical Christian that
believes
these I do believe all these ideas that
doesn't mean you have to put them forth
in government policy meaning that you
personally would want to partake in this
whether it's sex or drugs or and that's
fine
like for example we've talked I think
privately about you know drugs I think
you should be able put what you want in
your body I've never done drugs I don't
plan on doing drugs but why is it my
problem that you're doing that right so
that's a personal versus policy versus
kind of public policy so when you talk
to the more old-school conservatives on
that because so let's just forget all
the all the other drugs for a second
because I think there's a secondary
thing when you talk about the highly
addictive ones but let's just talk about
Marilyn are you list yeah just stop at
marijuana so on marijuana when you talk
to the more old-school conservatives I
simply don't understand the position
because I get it you guys want to have a
certain moral center that you don't want
to deviate against I understand that but
that Center then I mean this is what
you're getting to it then Bibi eighths
from your state's right stuff your
limited government stuff and it's like
those things are in constant conflict
then it's defend and why leave it to
Chuck Schumer to say that marijuana
should be a states rights issue like
when I heard him say that I was like oh
yeah like why [ __ ] yeah why give him
that yeah a little win yeah and so
here's my only contribution I think to
the whole marijuana debate where I come
from people should be able to do what
they want in their body but when it
starts to get into the glorification of
the substance that's where I'm gonna
push back and and that's where you not
gonna have an interesting discussions
you know
will it make society a better place over
the next twenty thirty years if more
people are doing marijuana maybe maybe
not I don't know I mean if you are doing
it instead of pharmaceuticals maybe but
if you have a bunch of fourteen year
olds that are you know consuming edibles
I don't know if that's a great thing
yeah alright however I that doesn't mean
that it should be illegal yeah and that
that's a really important thing and
that's where principles come in is you
can disagree with something
fundamentally and still think that other
people should be able to do it that
takes tolerance that takes maturity and
that takes us that that's what a civil
society is all about so are you pleased
then watching the way conservatives have
moved because when people say to me Oh
Dave you always go to these conservative
things and you know they secretly hate
gay people that's the most false
ridiculous thing
possibly think here yeah holy well I
never see it I mean I I mean I always
say this like I can't find them like you
can keep telling my and I found them
yeah I haven't I mean I did let's let's
let's talk about this for a minute you
and I spoke at Louisiana State
University now in the deep south in the
Bible Belt and you got a standing I
think I got more applause than you for
the record I'm just saying Lee and then
we also Candace Owens who got standing
up yeah I thought this place is supposed
to be backwards thinking and bigoted and
I mean I guarantee you we could we could
go to Universal family we could go to
the Lincoln Regan Day dinner in Alabama
and you would get that same sort of
response and so I haven't I'm speaking
at Liberty University in October and I
mean Jerry fall is an amazing guy and
they're gonna welcome you with open arms
and you get a standing ovation from them
now they have a biblical view of
marriage of which I have but your
biblical view of marriage does not have
to be what your public policy
prescription for marriages those are two
totally different things so then we're
so just let's go back to the question
then then where did the Conservatives
really get tripped up on this so I'm
glad to see it moving I'm what yeah I
think it's moving I get it but where did
they get screwed up and how do you fix
the remaining part of that it's where
the the evangelical right began to take
these deeply held religious beliefs and
see how popular they were in certain
parts of the country and then say well
let's just make it into that our public
policy platform and that's not what the
left is doing to us they're not taking
secular humanist trend very very kind of
I would say morally transient positions
now they're putting it in their public
policy positions they're doing it there
and we're accusing them on it right now
we're saying wait dude you can't tell me
how you can't tell me what bath I can't
have to use this bathroom or this or you
can't tell me how to live my life and I
wait wait a second a lot of Republic of
doing this back in the 70s and 80s do
you get a lot of Republicans pissed at
you when you acknowledge this because
this is this is a pretty big me a coal
pie thing for an evangelical Christian
and someone that's not even young we
shouldn't be afraid to admit mistakes
yeah I mean if we think that we've that
we've done brilliantly as a country
throughout the last 30 years on every
issue I mean come on that's a foolish
position to have and if you if you look
at it brilliant if Buckley was super
libertarian on certain issues really
libertarian I mean he was he was for the
legalization of marijuana
I mean William F Buckley that the
founder of National Review is for
legalization of marijuana and that's
that's a position a lot of people you
know are surprised to hear and yeah do I
get a lot of backlash I get disagreement
but I'd also I'm very and I qualified in
a very certain sense that I hold these
positions but there has to be in the way
that you create public policy if every
single individual says I'm gonna have my
worldview get put into law you have what
you have left is chaos
you've California where you have all
these little sub-tribes lobbying for the
most lunatic minority oppression
Olympics as you call it policy positions
and that's a really dangerous thing and
then you see how it ends up working
because my parents were visiting for the
last week and my dad was amazed at the
amount of tent cities we've got going up
in all these places these progressive
utopia's that are supposed to be the
friendliest to the people and everything
else you know yeah and so anyway that
that so that's the one thing I think
that conservatives are getting better at
now yeah I really do and I think
President Trump has done a great job of
this I have to say he's done a great job
of this he has been anti Dogma and I
love being I love the idea of crushing
pre-existing dogma or at least
challenging it because if some dogmas
good and it should be upheld there's
some things that shouldn't be so for
example one piece of dogma in our
society is hard work is a good thing
okay
that's good great let's keep that but
then there's other pieces of dogma that
let's just declare war in every country
that looks at us funny really that's
what Republicans should believe mmm-hmm
like after the horrendous Iraq war and
the endless Afghanistan war we should
still just be more happy and
trigger-happy at every corner I don't
think so isn't it strange now how the
media is sort of painting conservatives
as the anti-war party and a bizarre
sense so like Helen tell me policy is
like you know all against war and now
they're making it sound like she's a
conservative it's I thought this goes
back to what Dennis Prager talks about
the left has no principles and the Fed
is the left
there's just whatever side helps them
get power and I there's this what the
mayor of Baltimore she goes on
television the day that the president
Trump correctly decided not to execute a
missile strike that would have killed
120 Iranians she says well this is a
huge sign of weakness against President
and I saw this I said only president
Democratic Democrat to accuse him of not
declaring a war on a sovereign it is
that his gift more than anything else if
you were to you know him obviously but
if you were to whittle away everything
else is that the gift that somehow he
has that pinpoint precision ability to
find out what their weaknesses and get
them to use it against themselves
constantly it's one of his greatest
gifts I think he has a lot of them I
just he's able to expose the hypocrisy
within them so brilliantly and even
deeper than that I I think it's a I
think it's a very interesting thing he's
able to pull out the radicalism within
the left and whether it's a good thing a
bad thing things a good thing as you can
see who they really are I think it's a
bad thing because I'm more people than
become radical you know and that sort of
is where we're at right now right like
oh my god he's kind of exposing the hell
out of him and and actually you know
it's funny every time he exposes them
for something I'm like oh that thing
that I was talking about as a lefty like
when I still considered myself left him
like oh yeah yeah that's the thing I was
talking about three years ago now it's
just burst forth for everyone to see but
it is a catch-22 right because on one
hand you're exposing it that's good
sunlight on the other hand then it's
suddenly well there's equal to us in
this well consequence databases so then
President Trump exposes the radicalism
which is good so we can see who these
people really are we can see who ill on
all my Rasheeda Talib Ayanna Presley and
Alexander Kashia Cortes we can see who
they really are and the ideas they hold
which is good that's always a good thing
but then what happens is the media hates
Trump so much they modernize these ideas
they also make it oh it's not that bad
that Elon Omar's says that some people
did something about 9/11 it's not that
bad that Alexandria Kai's do Cortes
calls herself a socialist and then they
almost make it palatable and we're
digestible and you have more people then
embrace these radical positions and
that's that I guess that's that's where
we are i I'm a little troubled by that
and I do want to make a really
interesting point that I want everyone
listening to this and watching this to
think about which is what makes this
particular struggle versus leftist
Marxism and kind of Western society
values so unique it's mean I don't know
might in my knowledge
never happened before almost every one
of these revolutions that we can point
to her last hundred years the Russian
Revolution the Chinese Revolution
every time that Marxists have taken over
a government and you see it through the
universities that similar but they are
always pro nation state like the Russian
Revolution they were pro Russia mmm-hmm
they were that's interesting you see
they were there for the country and so
they were able to win over the
countrymen because they're well we love
the country more we want this is so
different they're actually trying to
assume power by being against the
country yeah this the founding
principles were able the founders are
earlier let's take down all the statues
it's Anthea linskey I al instant talked
about embracing and he was essentially
telling people how to lie to get the
power that essentially the doctrine of
saw linskey but Olinsky talked about
using the main symbols and the main
sayings of a country to get to power and
never diminish them Betsy Ross oh my
gosh yeah I heard about that so Saul
linski would have said Colin Kapernick
you're a fool you should have embraced
the Betsy Ross flag and said she was a
feminist and she would be upset with
where America is today that's what Saul
linski with us all right
we've never worked with this sort of
insurgency what do you think it's
possible I mean the the place that I've
sort of gotten to them is okay so let's
just say we disagree with ya most
everything they say right I don't you
know I try not to impugn people's
motives I tend to think at this point
that their motives are bad and that they
really know that you know they're
they're being owned every every other
day you know there's so II some clip of
them just saying something awful and not
knowing what they're saying or they
can't respond to a basic question are
you for left-wing terrorism you know
like they can't say no I'm not for
terrorism etc etc how much of it do you
think is just that they genuinely and I
hate to say this because this is not how
I operate a get people that I disagree
with politically but that they genuinely
just want to create chaos that that
their the chaos makers and then they'll
have say the Warrens or the Bernese
clean it up at a nicer level or
something like that but they're just on
the ground just creating as much chaos
as possible depends on you're talking
about so if you talk about con talk
about those days before yeah this
allowed to leave Presley
Tezz and I'm thinking I'm forgetting one
more Omar yeah so you get to first ask
the question is do they want what's best
for America and that's a really hard
question to answer
and I it depends like what you mean by
right what's best right but I do you
think here's another great cruiser
question do you think they're thankful
to be in America like do you think
they're overflowing with gratitude I
don't get that impression I get
bitterness it seems that they're bitter
that when they're walking the halls but
they're committed I mean you see it yeah
you see it right that they're there on a
mission that there's anger driving them
that there's something they believe that
this system that we're living in this
beautiful country is so much opportunity
so much blessing so much overflowing
abundance for all people that they see
something that I don't see and that you
don't see and of course we see problems
right we see our inner cities ruined we
see all these sorts of things but we
also understand that on the moving
average this country's been unbelievable
and continues to be in the rien bracing
those ideas will make it more so I don't
feel as if that they're thankful to be
in this country and so there are always
people though in every major
civilization like this that kind of to
use the Joker term just kind of want to
see the world burn mm-hmm and I don't
know if that's them or not but it sure
they sure sound like that at times and I
I find it that they use every single
instance of political exploitation
opportunity to try to advance their own
political agenda to get further into
power and it's a very dangerous position
because any sort of cross-examination of
these people they immediately excuse you
of the most vile things yeah you're
racist I mean it's always it's always
you're racist you're a [ __ ] it's too
bad because I could not care less about
their gender or their color ever ever
interview look when I criticize them I'm
not criticizing them because of their
race I'm criticizing because what they
say in their worldview and they just
happen to be that race no I think this
is an afterthought I mean it would be
the same thing of Adam Schiff was saying
I mean I've had plenty of sex pants by
the way right I've had plenty of fun at
Chuck Schumer's expense a Nancy Pelosi
expense but the one time you accuse
these other people you know receipt it
to leave and Presley
Cortez you accrues that squad if you
will all of a sudden you're called these
horrible names and you know it's too bad
about it is that there is really is amid
the world there is but the more that
that term is thrown around flippantly
and just so kind of haphazardly it
cheapens real racism so i know you don't
want to help the democrats but if you
were say a saner democrat than them if
you were just a little more of a
moderate and it's so funny because now
Pelosi who really is pretty far left in
another itself yeah but now she's being
framed as the centrist democrat even
though she's certainly not the type of
liberal because her answer is always
government that that i would care about
but it let's say there were a couple
are there any democrats that you think
are sort of more blue dog older that guy
knows on the stage from maryland Delaney
yeah he was he talked about he was just
on the wrong stage i mean i mean he was
talking about this country has been
great to a lot of people we need to get
back to national service you're saying
some things actually agreed with so okay
so then if you were talking about yeah
right so the one guy maybe Hickenlooper
but then he said some nutty stuff so one
guy okay but if you were talking
directly to him and you wanted to help
this guy regain the party but what would
you tell some ways I'd to wouldn't you
before a guy that wants Trump to
obviously win again but in some ways I
want a functioning second party like in
some ways I want to party that will step
up and say you know what we do want
regulatory reform you know what we do
want to fund our military look it I'd
I'd be nice yeah like we don't want open
borders how about that how'd that and I
think Delaney could come to a agreement
with that
what would my advice be to him I mean
you have to fight the radicals within
your own party before you even focus on
you know president Trump because you've
got something very very dangerous within
your own party I think and Who am I to
give advice to the left I mean I want
President Trump to win in a massive
landslide and I believe is on his way to
win for many different reasons this
being one of the contributing factors
the fact of how radical the left has
become but it's not exclusive to that
but I don't think that's gonna happen
Dave I'm gonna tell you why
well I've seen no evidence of it you'd
think that having Trump win an election
might have caused a little self
reflection so here's the question when
you and I go to college campus is a
turning point USA with turning-point USA
are the students more like the squad or
more like Delaney the students that come
to us - well I got that like us or
radical
tester type oh no their of course
they're much more like the squad of
course that's the leading indicator yeah
that's the harbinger whatever happens on
college campuses will soon happen in the
halls of Congress the leading indicator
of a culture is what happens on college
campuses
ilan Omar AOC they got educated on these
college campuses or lack thereof or
indoctrinated they got radicalized yeah
and then they get set forth and they're
committed they have their marching
orders if you look at a prototype of
what the campus creates the University
if there was a formula of what they're
trying to put into the world it is
Alexandria
Acacio Cortez everything about her
constantly wrong but never in doubt
consistently challenging our history
totally questioning any sort of power
structure at be no belief in national
sovereignty at all and chaos chaos chaos
that's the university that's what
they're creating all right so you don't
want to help them that much I know I
mean I would like to see people like
Delaney you know take take root but
here's the other point so here's the
other thing that no one talks about
which i think is an interesting point
which is in politics you're always kind
of looking at who's my base how am i
catering to that base and so when Donald
Trump ran for the presidency and you
went down the Golden escalator he did
something that actually made the
radicals the main Democrats become more
radically saying how is that possible he
stole their base away from them so he
stole ten million Democrats that are
Catholics that are union workers that
are electricians that are middle class
people that have voted Democrats since
1970 and now they're registered Trump
people and they go to the rallies I mean
you look at the data that I've actually
the Trump rallies just amazing
percentage of registered Democrats
Panetta's and they end up voting for
Trump they think nothing of it well
they're basically getting the
disaffected Bernie people so that saw
how corrupt the Democrats like blow it
all up so then what happens if the
Democrats all this and have 10 million
less Democrats mind you Republicans bled
a little they bled some suburban voters
mm-hm they bled some you know
upper-middle class voters just because
they didn't like Trump style but the
offset was generally positive in the
states that really mattered
which were the traditional Democrats
Democrats look at their kind of roster
like oh my gosh we're down to ten
million voters and then some lunatic
proposes in a room well instead of
trying to win those people back why
don't we go one more people in Malibu
and Manhattan Oh a great idea that is
yeah and then they start embracing these
horrendously radical ideas as if they
can get more people maybe they can I
mean I've been proven wrong before but
somehow they can win another ten million
people around the green New Deal
universal health care for illegals
complete and total open borders shutting
down people you disagree with
prosecuting people that dare say
something critical of a member of
Congress which represent Rico Wilson
said yeah oh yeah that was a real or or
you know you know Dave I've done a lot
of traveling I have to say a kitchen
table issue in Pennsylvania is making
sure that the Boston bomber can vote
they're all about it right now it's like
their one issue voters on that it's
amazing how many people in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania come up through they said
Charlie whatever candidate makes sure
that terrorists can vote they got my
vote to make of course I'm being
facetious the more they look but
audience they cater but does that tell
you really how insidious this way of
thinking is so like during the first
debate when they all spoke Spanish and
to me it was the word fringing the worst
sort of pandering it would have been
like if this was 1940's and we had an
influx of Irish Americans and they were
up we're gonna give you all a punch at
all it's like what are you guys doing
but it's the worst sort of pandering and
yet they keep going to it so it's almost
as if the ideology actually overrides
what you're saying would just be sort of
sound political you know maneuvering to
win an electorate do whatever they need
to do to assume power that's the left
and so if you come from the the
acceptance that they're trying to
deconstruct this country then it all
starts to make sense
that why would you want to have open
borders you want to destroy the
sovereignty why would you want to give
away stuff you can so horrible and we
should let everyone in by the way this
is what I can't understand a couple
things you got me on this the Democrats
they were this horrible country
albertson one of the worst why the hell
would you want to be president of that
country like I hate this country
yeah I want to be president of it that's
a really interesting that's how good
they are that's right no but they want
to save us from ourselves right because
they're on the philosopher-king that
yeah we'll save us the second thing is
this is if we were really this racist
bigoted homophobic horrendous country
what are millions of people trying to
come here and just from a more broad
standpoint we take it half the world's
immigrants every single year we're
taking a million legal immigrants every
single year well the most accepting
generous benevolent country ever to
exist in a history of the world
I think we're overly generous at times
actually I think our generosity actually
come back to bite us at times I think
that Trump has brought rational
self-interest back to the conversation
of the nation-states they're just real
quick on the immigration stuff and then
I really do want to get to something
ours disagree on but on the immigration
stuff look I get it there are videos of
Obama of Pelosi of Chuck Schumer of Bill
Clinton all saying virtually the exact
same things that Trump now says and
Trump is considered racist now I get it
Trump also has a strange intonation and
inflection when he speaks and he can be
a little sloppier on some of the
language or may be intentionally
inflammatory or yeah and that's fine I'm
it doesn't even matter which way you
look at it the point is that what he's
actually saying is not different really
than what Obama's saying I even just
this morning I tweeted out a clip about
Obama saying virtually the same things
that Trump says now do you think there's
anything that could ruin can do if you
think his policies around immigration
are moral and just and reasonable is
there anything you could do just around
the language that might ease up some of
this tension yeah I mean the one
suggestion that I've made publicly and
I'll make it again is we have to own the
legal immigrant I loved when Trump
talked about the big door I want to hear
more about the door I wanted him to say
wall and door that'd be just my one
piece of recommendation because I was
watching this ridiculous clip on Twitter
the other day and the left the left mmm
they shadowbox and make it seem as if if
you're accusing border jumpers and line
cutters I don't call them immigrants
they're border jumpers and line cutters
because you know minimun grayness
someone wastes their turn that comes to
this country correctly which is why
we're seeing tons of studies now where
legal immigrants first-generation
illegal immigrants are the most anti yes
illegal immigrant a way to process their
to get a green but all these amazingly
hard difficult things we can make that
easier but the second thing is the left
they make it seem as if if you're
against line cutters and border jumpers
you're somehow against
legal immigrants mm-hmm and I take the
position and some people on the right
disagree this position I think we should
have more legal immigrants I think we
should be the Kentucky basketball of
immigrants I want the smartest richest
most aspirational creative people in the
world to come here that are under the
age of 35 this should be the laboratory
of excellence for the world I want the
best Koreans Indonesians Somalians
Germans I don't care where you're from i
if you have aspiration come to America
that should be the advertisement and boy
this Donald Trump is great in marketing
he could sell that in a second could
mean he could do a world tour just on
the legal immigration tour and I think
that would be the media would find a way
here's the link sign up I think the
media obvious on the Left would be
totally again for you know okay they'd
be building the wall for him kid you
know but the last thing is this is look
if he illegals were voting Republican
and they were tend to vote Republican
the Democrats would already have the
wall built and say anyone who opposes
the wall is against the black community
right they would write some ways in it
yeah but actually is it is correct that
open borders hurt the black community
believe it or not but that's another
another whole thing alright so I want to
back up to one other thing in there and
then let's get to the tech stuff which
is super important on how sort of
conservatives are people on the right
have to sort of widen the net right now
how do you think the messaging could be
about making room for secular
conservatives are secular Republicans so
someone like Heather McDonald who I've
had on the show who is she's a religious
I think I think she's an atheist yes she
said I find pissed petitionary prayer
futile and I love Heather I heard that
is come on yeah they disagree every
other okay but you want to live in the
same society as her and you probably
agree worsen I probably religious
fundamentalist so but so but I think and
I when I was on Candace's show under you
I brought this up that if that there's
such lunacy on the left that to me all
the right has to do well all
conservatives have to do is just be at
every turn be a tiny bit better like you
don't have to be you know to be like now
I just a little bit better what do you
think conservatives or Republicans or
whatever can do for the disaffected
lefty that still is secular maybe has
some religious belief but it's not sort
of a corner tenon or whatever it is what
do you think that people on the right
I have to give the conservatives credit
I think Donald Trump's done a lot of
that I mean Donald Trump has been
amazingly embracing of the of angelical
community but he himself and I don't
want to speak for him was definitely
more secular yeah right I mean he was
not running a campaign like Mike
Huckabee a Rick Santorum was in 2016
would I think you would agree yeah for
sure it's much more based on ideas in
the revitalization in the nation-state
and those guys actually have very little
influence now over modern Republican
politics yeah and and look I agree with
again I want to just make sure I
reinforced this I agree with them on
basically a lot of things are saying
personally and now my pro-life position
I book is is I could defend that from a
secular lens if you've got another four
hours weekend we might dive in or you
could talk to Lila Rose about that yes
Lila is really great we've done that one
I know it's amazing pockets I listened
to it a couple times she was really
really good on it but the the thing that
I find really interesting about this is
that the Republicans are becoming the
tolerant ones we really are and it's
it's the Republican conservative ones
that have the most intellectual
diversity that have the most I believe
it's gonna have the most religious
diversity where we're trending towards
that and I like to think that turning
point USA has really been on the cutting
edge of this I think we've been on the
cutting edge of it yeah listen I go to
turn boy there are kids in yarmulkes
there are black kids there are Muslim
kids there are trans people and we have
a we have a spokesman Rob Smith who's a
veteran of our country happens to be gay
black super articulate you know we can't
so ins was with us for a while and did
an amazing job I mean I would like to
think that we're practicing what we're
preaching I would like to think that and
also on doing events with you is so fun
because it's one thing to say you're the
tolerant one and then you're the only
one I think you know but it's fun guys
than you and I will disagree on a couple
things but the marketplace of ideas in
the collision of ideas it also keeps you
you know like any muscle if it atrophies
if you don't use it atrophies the same
thing goes with your policy positions in
your politics and I really believe part
of the reason why the left has become so
radical is they haven't had to debate
yeah they got they got fat because it
was so easy to call it ver and racist
and sit back yeah
so they ALC Alexandra Cortez has she
ever gone on a centre-right platform
that's a really good question is it is I
I know of no knowledge of it ever since
that one woman asked her three tough
questions about and she said Palestine
was occupying Israel or something she
has done nothing but friendly media yeah
where I would love to sit down with her
and even though I've gone after her
obviously I would treat her of course we
I know you would and I have to and I
would ask her direct questions and I'd
hope she would ask questions out of me
[Music]